Gear for Floyd talked about it.
Apparently,
this is one thing I can tell you.
Dana told me that Floyd wants to make a deal in the UFC like legitimately,
and I go,
did he?
I could.
So I texted him,
I go,
this void really talking about fighting MMA.
He goes,
yeah,
he's fucking crazy.
I told him to get killed,
but he's still talking about doing it.
Hmm.
Whoa.
For us,
a hobby teases GSP versus Mayweather or McGregor as next fight.
We need a mega fight.
Okay,
let me just stop this nonsense right there.
She GSP just fought at 185 pounds.
If you fucking really think that Floyd Mayweather is going to fight GSP kiss,
shut the fuck up.
Just stop.
Just stop it.
We may where there's going to be like a pass.
That guy's huge GSP.
So big.
We would have to be like,
like joints.
You'd have to get GSP to die it down to one 55 and he would be so depleted and
making one 55 Floyd would light him up like a Christmas tree if Floyd in light
him up like a Christmas tree.
Anyway.
I mean,
they're going to fight in MMA.
He gets smushed 100% there's no way.
Stop or fight one 85 gs pain.
No,
no,
but they might fight at one 70 if the money was right.
If,
if,
if Mcgregor won't take it.
I don't know about that man.
That could be a mega,
mega fine.
That could be a $20 million fight.
Conor might want an extra 20 spent a lot of money on Versace.
He's always wearing furs and shit.
Flying around in private jets.
That shit's pricey,
man.
Is the latest with Mcgregor like what's going on like today?
Hashtag Bowlin that's what's going on.
He's on top of the world,
man.
Look that guy.
Let him enjoy this.
He's got plenty of time to come back to fighting.
Just have fun,
man.
Stare at your watches.
Take Instagram pictures of your Dick.
Who Cares?
You're the fucking man.
You made $100 million.
You're not even 30 relax.
Do whatever the fuck you want that no need to force him to come back and fight.
But if he does come back and fight,
if he,
if he thinks an MMA fight with GSP is a good idea,
like that's a big guy.
He's very big.
George Saint Pierre is one of the best fighters of all time.
Take that fight.
He's so fucking good at grappling.
But Connor might go fucking now,
fuck it.
Give me a couple months to put some weight on.
That's not a good fight for them.
But if that's where all the money is,
who knows?
I think Tony Ferguson is to fight.
That's the fight I want to see now in more until I see what happens with Barboza
and Norma Madoff.
Right.
The problem is if Barboza and near mcmeadow fight and Durga Madoff smashes
Barboza he's gotta be next in line for the title fight,
right?
Nope.
You don't think so?
I not fighting.
Tony is the Oh,
but counters out fighting.
Well then to vacate,
right?
What does it say here?
Sorted rounds tonight.
It SGB BG,
Ireland.
He's trained.
I mean,
he's definitely not fat.
You look at him there.
He's in shape for sure.
I mean,
but he might just be working on his skills.
He's got $100 million.
I would not be mad at a world fight if they decided to like strip him of his
belt and have Tony Versus Cubby for the undisputed title.
I wouldn't be mad at that.
Yeah,
that'll probably happen.
I would not be mad at that.
I liked that fight.
Tony.
So fun.
He's so wild to watch,
man.
You know,
like when he was fighting Kevin Lean,
he's walking towards him when his hands down and just pot shot him and slowly
wearing on him,
slowly chipping them away and then the finish him off his back.
Come on man.
Sweet.
How many people get finished off their back?
Do you still a lot of sweet things that,
um,
that he came up with,
right?
They're like,
uh,
working,
you know,
there's different ways you can get up off your back with the cage.
Just like basic wall walking and stuff like that.
But you can't walk,
walk on everybody.
Right.
It all depends on where your level of wall walking is and how good is your
opponent at countering that?
What did you think when Kevin Lee walked in with Javier staph infection on his
chest?
Did you notice it?
I was like,
cool.
I hope he's weak
because he was forced.
Tony said Das.
Tony,
did you notice as the staff goes?
Yeah,
I was trying to punch it,
but what,
what tone?
The Way Tony got up off the cage when,
when Kevin Lee put them up against the cage,
he actually can opener Kim from the bottom and full guards.
Okay.
Tony was head was against the cage and Kevin Lee's head was right here.
So he basically did like a Muay Thai clinch,
like,
um,
can open it up right at the bottom so he couldn't get hit.
And then he had,
he had,
um,
his left foot on the hip and his right leg was just around his,
his ribs.
And then at the right time,
Kevin was naturally trying to push,
pull out cause he was holding him in,
he couldn't hit him.
He was safe against the cage.
And then Tony put both feet on the hips,
pushed him up,
kicked up,
and then says,
stood up bra like,
wow,
we're going to be doing that one.
Yeah,
I'm going to be,
I mean he,
Kevin Lee couldn't do anything.
He had him exactly where he wanted him against the cage on his back.
Head pressed against the fence,
but he couldn't do anything cause Tony did a can opener arm.
No one,
no one does that.
I know he's in it.
He's an interesting guy,
man.
That was the first time we ever did that and it was crazy.
Yeah,
it was perfect.